mesdames messieurs bonsoir il est bien
rare que le geste rejoignent le discours
encore plus rare que les idées même les
plus généreuses résiste longtemps à
l'épreuve des réalités c'est vrai
notamment du discours politique ce qui
explique peut-être le décalage de plus
en plus marquée entre le monde politique
précisément et les citoyens pourtant ce
soir
une initiative que l'on jugera sur ses
résultats permet de penser que la
décrispation peut être une réalité
immédiate
cette initiative a été prise par les
maires des cinquante et une villes
françaises de plus de 100000 habitants
toutes tendances confondues ils ont
décidé de mettre au point un dispositif
d'urgence pour enrayer la montée de la
pauvreté dans notre pays
un phénomène né de la crise et qui
apparaissent chaque jour plus
préoccupant l'abbé pierre était
d'ailleurs reçu cet après midi par le
premier ministre pour parler de ce
problème car la situation est telle
aujourd'hui que le bénévolat ne suffit
plus jérôme baugnies et dominique
tierces
pardon monsieur kone vous m'aider pour
pouvoir manger
pardon monsieur
pardon monsieur pourriez vous m'aider
pour prouver aux gens si vous pourriez
vous m'aider pour pouvoir manger ici on
ne brûle
il ne faudrait trouver du travail ils
sont comme lui plus d'un million à vivre
de mendicité de soupe populaire et
d'être charitable sans profession ou
plus souvent chômeurs en fin de droits
toujours résignés on les appelle
pudiquement les nouveaux pauvres
monsieur s'il vous plaît c'était comme
une pièce de chômage 300 qu'est ce que
vous avez comme en soit aucune en tête
comme métier nous travaillerons de
poisson
selon les statistiques 600000 personnes
ne touche plus d'allocations chômage
mais la réalité semble largement dépassé
cette évaluation la pauvreté la misère
c'est le combat d'un homme l'abbé pierre
qui depuis 30 ans alerte l'opinion
ce qui est très grave c'est que
l'opinion publique de notre pays comme
de n'importe lequel des pays
industrialisés de l'europe n'a
absolument pas conscience que un temps
est fini et que nous sommes nous avons
commencé à devenir un pays pauvre et où
il y à l'obligation de se résigner et
accepter de vouloir qui que ce soit qui
gouverne de monsieur marcia monsieur
chirac avec n'importe qui les données
fondamentales sont que nous sommes
condamnés au partage est pas possible qu
une nation vive avec le quart de sa
population valide inoccupés le père qui
rentrent qui voit rentrer ses enfants de
l'école et qui a honte parce que les
enfants savent que papa m'a fichu depuis
longtemps déjà les évêques de france et
organisations charitables en ce même cri
d'alarmé
aujourd'hui les hommes politiques
l'entente enfin leur bureau dette
sociale leur mairie sont submergés par
la pauvreté les villes avec leur budget
difficile actuellement n'en peuvent plus
et simon keay c'est une charge qui
devait être prise en compte par l'état
ne veulent pas lui renvoyer cette charge
mais c'est des gars tout prêt à
collaborer et à participer avec avec
l'état au soulagement de ces nouveaux
pauvres prise de conscience ou véritable
récupération électoraliste la pauvreté
est à présent un thème mobilisateur pour
toutes les formations politiques
mais l'hiver approche et les discours
doivent de manière urgente céder la
place aux actes
with